growth in Chinese exports slowed in
December from the previous month
compared year by year they were up by
just over four percent as against
13-cent in november and alice a chinese
companies are worried about the unstable
global economy a surging yuan and higher
labor costs but the outlook is generally
upbeat well what do you want if the
international and domestic economies
don't suffer from major risks I believe
China's foreign trade will enter a phase
of stable growth and the quality and
efficiency of foreign trade development
is likely to improve further by the same
year-on-year comparison imports to china
grew by eight percent economists hailed
that development as a sign that domestic
demand is growing last year the
government spent more on infrastructure
projects to stimulate the economy some
analysts see a more substantial shift
underway in Chinese foreign trade policy
if the government loosens its grip on
the yuan and imports keep rising more
people could benefit from Chinese
prosperity